good news for movie fans james cameron
says avatar 2 has finished production
and filming on avatar 3 is nearly
complete the canadian-born director
shared the news with arnold
schwarzenegger in a chat for the 2020
austrian world summit
on climate action i know you're in the
middle of shooting avatar i know you
have to get up now to
do this interview because of the time
change here in new zealand and all that
stuff
uh tell me is there anything newsworthy
that we should know
from a minister movie coming out in the
theaters and what's going on there well
covet hit us like it hit everybody hit
us hard
we lost about four and a half months of
production as a result of that
we've rolled around one more full year
for a release in december of 22. that's
been
that's been announced already now that
doesn't mean that i have an extra year
to finish the film
because the day we deliver avatar 2
we'll just start working
on finishing avatar 3. you should not be
[Music]
here well this is your fault
i need your help avatar 2 was one of the
first films to go back in production
following the pandemic shutdown in march
the country has since been successful in
putting a halt to the spread of the
virus and began lifting restrictions in
most areas
cast and crew returned to new zealand in
june and cameras were rolling following
the 14-day mandatory quarantine
so where we are right now i'm down in
new zealand shooting we're shooting the
remainder of the live action we've got
about 10
left to go we're 100 complete on avatar
2
and we're sort of 95 complete on
on avatar 3. um so we're just uh
we're very lucky in that we chose this
as our production
site years ago we made the first film
here in new zealand
and it turns out to be one of the it's
ranked either the first or second
best country in the world for its
covered response we're able to operate
we're able to shoot and we're able to
have a more or less normal life here so
we're very fortunate so i don't see any
roadblocks
to us getting the picture finished uh
getting both pictures finished
other than that i can't tell you about
the story i can't give you any big
scoops
you're certainly welcome as an
individual to come anytime and i'll show
you everything but
in terms of what i can release i believe
in the mystery and the great reveal
well first of all as you know i've
visited your studio and you
many times doing the shooting of avatar
i always enjoyed i love the technology
and i love the way
uh how genius you work and you know the
collaboration and all of the stuff so
congratulations on all that great work
and good luck with
avatar and thank you very much for the
work you're doing for the environment
thank you very much